tous les lundis depuis un an
des milliers de personnes manifestent à
relie la capitale de la caroline du nord
contre les politiques républicaines les
mots landmann days sont devenus le
symbole d'une révolte populaire
ces cercueils incarne la mise à mort de
la réforme de la santé par l'est
républicain de cet état
ces citoyens marche au bureau du
gouverneur dont les décisions prises
d'assurance santé
un demi million de personnes
le toit violet web yuda le fils de cette
femme est mort à cause d'une décision
politique affirme le révérend barber
c'est lundi de la colère ont été lancées
par ce pasteur il dénonce ce qu'il
qualifie d' extrémisme de droite aux
états unis il reproche aussi aux
républicains d'avoir coupé dans les
dépenses en éducation et réduit les
périodes de votation h parking pour
jouer ces politiques sont indéfendables
elles font mal aux pauvres autant blanco
noir dit celui qui fait la promotion des
valeurs morales mais la valeur suprême
dans cette campagne pour un siège au
sénat à washington
ses larges ouïes washington par le cnpac
élections de mi-mandat en caroline du
nord va coûter 100 millions de dollars
dix mille publicité ont été diffusés en
une seule semaine au mois d'octobre
les démocrates ont dépensé deux fois
plus que les républicains la campagne la
plus chère aux états unis
c'est le far west ici en termes d'argent
affirme cet ancien stratège démocrate
tout cet argent vient pervertir la
démocratie - une pointure les gens
d'affaires très riches achètent de l'
influence dit il des millions de dollars
sont dépensés pour soutenir ou détruire
un candidat de l' influence qui provient
de groupes tels americans for prosperity
financé par les multimilliardaires
choses et david cox oise tueur des
grosses têtes buriné au kobus une
organisation dont les bénévoles cognent
aux portes pour que l'entreprise privée
triomphe sur les gouvernements
personne ici ne tente d'acheter l'
élection déclare john bryson d'americans
for prosperity le groupe demande aux
électeurs de ne pas voter pour la
candidate démocrate qui mène de justesse
dans les sondages ce sont ceux qui
manifestent les lundis qui sont des
extrémistes pas nous
pendant ce temps à 200 km de rallye le
pasteur barber poursuit sa croisade
contre large
il supplie les électeurs de voter contre
les républicains
rollier nous sommes maintenant une armée
dit il qui manifestent dans plusieurs
états oui bio mais me garder vos bons
viens d'entendre un plaidoyer en faveur
du changement christian et justement on
s'attend à du changement de main les
démocrates pourraient perdre leur
majorité au sénat
vous savez céline la présidence n'est
pas en jeu la chambre des représentants
va rester sous contrôle républicain est
bon les républicains pourraient
effectivement la prendre le contrôle du
sénat c'est donc au sénat que ça se
passe demain soir céline les
républicains qui doivent remporter ces
sièges de plus pour contrôler la chambre
haute
il y aura des luttes très très chaude
dans une dizaine d'états j'vous part de
l'arkansas de la caroline du nord de la
georgie de la louisiane et du colorado
pour le nommer que ceux là
ce sera une soirée remplie d connu une
campagne électorale qui a été fait à
coup de milliards de dollars pour
l'ensemble des états unis
je vous parlais dans mon reportage en
caroline 2 millions là on parle de 3,7
milliards qu'on a coûté cette élection
de mi-mandat aux etats-unis c'est un
record
quatre cent mille messages publicitaires
si les dons étaient diffusés durant ces
élections de mi-mandat un but partout
aux états unis alors les électeurs
américains qui sont prêts à retourner à
leur match de football et à leur télé
romans préférés sans être constamment
interrompu par des politiciens qui
s'invectivent way en tout cas on se
souvient du temps où barack obama était
le meilleur argument de vente des
démocrates aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
tout le contraire les temps ont bien
changé un mot un seul mot l'impopularité
barack obama est très impopulaire céline
sa réforme de la santé la montée du
groupe armé état islamique l'ebola lui
nuisent nuisent aux démocrates qui
semble qui tente de se faire élire en ce
moment chaque élection de mi-mandat
historiquement est un référendum sur la
performance du président et celle ci ne
fera pas exception
mais attention les électeurs ne sont pas
prêts à voter pour les républicains les
yeux fermés il etienne responsable entre
autres des nombreuses impasses à
washington donc si le sénat devient à
majorité républicaine
ça va compliquer drôlement l'avis du
président obama un président démocrate
et s'il veut par exemple faire passer sa
réforme sur l'immigration il devra le
faire par décret on se reparle tout ça
demain soir merci beaucoup question je
vous en prie sedin